the knives are out for Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis and his takedown of woke
education Michigan's Governor Gretchen
Whitmer tries to school DeSantis on what
is best for kids
I don't wage culture wars I fight
culture wars because I'm focused on
solving problems I think it's incredibly
destructive when people just try to pit
others against one another Stoke fear I
think it's a really destructive way to
lead it but maybe what Democrats are
afraid to admit is that their own
policies are contributing to the Next
Generation failing in schools in
Democrat LED Baltimore not a single
student in nearly two dozen schools is
proficient in math not one
and it is not for lack of money the
Baltimore city school budget balloon to
twenty one thousand dollars per student
last year that's about six thousand more
than the Nationwide average so let's
talk about the fact Greg that Gretchen
Whitmer says she doesn't engage in any
kind of culture wars
um and yet this is the governor that we
first heard about and by the way she has
refused to condemn pornographic books in
Michigan's taxpayer-funded schools you
think she's involved in her own culture
wars they prefer they prefer to blame
you I.E parents for noticing things yeah
like if you are if you kind of like you
you hear something you decide to go to a
school board meeting or you see a book
or something and you or you let's say
you just find the the entertainment that
is there is not age appropriate they
then look at you as the problem a
domestic terrorist but all you're really
doing is you're playing the role of a
pairing you're just going this is weird
go I got nothing against drag queen
Story Hour but not for my six-year-old
you know it's like I we're not about
banning books we're saying this book
isn't appropriate for this age that is
not Banning books which drive me a
little crazy is these daily videos of
the Grimace School violence I have I I
keep seeing this stuff and I keep
thinking is it because we all have
phones but there's like just these weird
beatdowns where the victim is completely
submissive and the aggressor just
aggresses and the teacher doesn't show
up until like it's near the end and then
and they're so feeble and maybe they're
it's because they're told not to
interrupt but I keep seeing more and
more and more of these and I'm wondering
if it's just because I'm looking for
them or they're looking for me or
they're actually happening more I don't
know all right Harold I mean the
Baltimore schools get uh almost six
thousand dollars more per student and
yet these kids are uh in a mess I mean
it's shameful it is and it says this is
happening I agree with you this is
happening in a lot of places
um the one one thing I think Governors
and Paul politicians all of us alike
should be happy that parents are more
involved and want to be more involved in
their kids education I hope that parents
Across the Nation will think about the
four or five things I think we have to
be teaching in our schools obviously
Math and Science in life skills and in
language and critical thinking skills I
don't care what ratio I don't care what
books that might be unleashing this and
activating this in kids these are the
things that we that we have to focus on
I would love for congress even even Mr
Comer's oversight committee we talked
about when when Biden provided the
relief for students in college we all
quarrel with that saying middle class
Americans and plumbers and others we're
funding school for kids that major in
art history nothing against art history
and other things where they weren't
contributing why hasn't Congress looked
at why tuition is rising so fast at
these schools and two the difference
between a four-year degree and a
two-year degree look I'm not going to
fault the santhis his state is moving up
in the rankings he's doing something
that's positive I'm not sure the woke
education thing is why but I'm happy to
have egg on my face and be proved wrong
on that what I hope we as a nation get
more focused on and if parents get more
focused on is raising the achievement
gaps like Finland South Korea and China
all their kids are performing better
than ours that ought to be the focus not
uh the kinds of things I think we
sometimes get invested in our own
country are huge that's a big
opportunity right yeah you know Dana 23
Baltimore schools have zero kids
proficient in math and yet when you
think about the United Federation of
teachers the money the coveted money
alone they should be so you know
animated with these students and Randy
Weingarten is no place to be found
there's let me guess she could went to
Ukraine do you remember yeah a couple of
times but they can't I would this is a
five alarm fire and it's not just
Baltimore there are many other places
and I think one of the reasons why we
really need to focus on this as a
country Corporate America needs to the
schools need to figure it out right away
is that in the last 20 years we went
away from teaching
the phonetic method and they went to
this whole thing of like we're going to
teach in a new way well the new way
isn't working we have evidence of that
and on the reading side the woman who
created the new way has even said whoa
my bad sorry and what happened during
covet is that parents were like oh wait
my kid can't read I can't get into food
so so where are all the squad members
talking about the inequality of
Education because
families that have the means will hire a
tutor
but a young black kid in Baltimore whose
mom maybe is working two jobs like she
can't do that right so and there's a new
governor in Maryland Westmore I think
he's an amazing guy and I think he'll do
a lot for that City but there's a whole
problem with the system and Charles
Payne was on America's Newsroom today
talking about this uh go back and watch
that interview we posted it it's very
moving and Powerful he has some very
interesting things to say and concerns
about this because those kids over their
lifetime will not achieve the kind of
wealth that their peers will achieve and
it's it's outrageous and this is not the
pursuit of happiness this is a if I were
those parents I would go against them
say this is the Civil Rights issue and I
would I would sue the school district
because they have to have to figure out
something the last thing I would say
about Rhonda Santos is the reason the
left drive it drives them crazy is he
makes them take positions on very
unpopular decisions
so he they have to basically say oh okay
well my opinion on drag queen's story
hour or whatever it might be they
actually have to do something about it
Glenn youngkin did the same thing that's
a threat you know just it's even it's
even worse to add to what Dana just said
is there's a couple hundred thousand
kids who didn't go back to school after
the pandemic yeah they're missing uh we
don't know where they are I hope we find
them but we haven't even kept track of
the migrants so I don't think we're
going to get to the bottom of that
Gretchen says that DeSantis devices but
she's calling your son racist and
suggesting you chop his ding dong off
what is that about and then on Baltimore
we have to stop expecting competence
these are government schools we
shouldn't expect competence from the
government yeah the government
fails us everywhere and then the worse
they do the more money they ask for
so we're actually buying bad results and
what do we get with bad results we get
bigger government to get worse results
bigger government and you shower these
idiots with money you know what they did
with the money they got from covert
relief they hired Hall monitors well the
students were remote learning
and they gave Hall monitors that didn't
monitor a single Hall
a bonus wow and then they gave bonuses
to teachers and gave raises to the
bureaucrats and the kids they didn't buy
a single laptop for in the entire city
of Baltimore and this is America I
wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now